The next piece we'll add to our app
is a Leanback details fragment.
When the user selects one of our movies,
we'd like to bring it front and center.
And we'll use the details
fragment to do just this.
The details fragment has three sections.
The first is an overview row,
which contains text fields like a title,
an author, and a description.
Below that is an actions row.
In our sample app, we've used the said
actions to watch a trailer, and
to buy and rent movies.
These actions of course,
are fully customizable.
Finally, if you scroll down you
can see a list of related movies.
Pretty cool, right?
The details fragment works in a similar
way as the browse fragment in
the previous lesson, it provides
the smooth animations and most of
the functionality behind the scenes, all
we have to do is add our content to it.
The pattern is the same as
in our previous lesson.
First, we create
a details activity class.
And it's only job will be to apply
a layout that contains
the details fragment.
As before, this layout does little else
except specify our details fragment.
But before we see how that works,
let's look at how we can start it up.
Here I am back in the browse fragment.
When the user selects a movie,
we'd like to show our details fragment.
And to do so, we're going to
add an ItemViewClickListener
to the browse fragment.
In the on activity created method,
uncomment set up event listeners.
And let's see how that method works.
Let's look inside
the ItemViewClickListener.
We have two different types
of cards in our display,
and this listener contains
logic to handle each.
The important part is that if a movie's
clicked, we fire an intent to start up
our details activity class, and we
include the selected movie as an extra,
so we can retrieve it later
from our details fragment.
The second listener on the browse
fragment is used to detect when a user
selects a movie.
These names can be
a little bit confusing, so
by select, I actually mean
that certain card has focus.
A neat trick is that inside this
listener we can update the background
image of the browse fragment
to reflect the selected movie.
To do so,
return to on activity created and
uncomment prepared background manager,
and setupEventListeners.
Let's run the project now and
see what we get.
Here, you can see the background's
changing to reflect the currently
selected card.
Pretty cool, right?
I won't go into the logic of how
the BackgroundManager, works but
there is one note.
Notice that if I scroll very quickly,
the background doesn't
immediately change.
Instead we wait for about a second
after a card has been selected
before adjusting the background.
This provides a much
smoother user experience.
Now let's see how to set
up the details fragment.
The pattern to set up
this class is pretty much
the same as the browse fragment.
I'll focus just on the new concepts, and
you can find more details in the notes.
We'll start by populating
the DetailsOverviewRow,
which is a class provided by Leanback.
And this is going to contain the title,
the author, and the description.
First, we'll pass it a reference
to the selected movie.
The DetailsOverviewRow will store this
as an object that we can access later.
Next we add actions.
The actions class is also
provided by Leanback.
To respond when one of our
action buttons is clicked,
we'll setup all callback later on.
First, it's important to understand
the DetailsOverviewRow will be presented
by DetailsOverviewRowPresenter.
Aren't Java naming
conventions just great?
They're so concise.
This presenter already knows
how to layout our actions row,
because that's built in to Leanback.
But we need to add our callbacks to it.
Here's where we do that, and
take a look at how these are handled.
The most important action starts
at the video playing activity
via the play back overlay fragment.
This is also provided by pingback,
and we'll see how it works later in our
lesson on the Universal Media Player.
Last, although our presenter
knows how to present actions,
we have to tell it how
to display our movie.
To do so,
we create a DetailsDescriptionPresenter.
This is a very simple class, which binds
our movie data to the details fragment.
One last new concept.
Our details fragment uses two
different presenters, one for
the overview row, and another for
the related videos row.
And by the way, if you look through the
code, the related videos row is built
identically to how a row of videos
was created in the browse fragment,
by using list rows and
a ListRowPresenter.
We'll need a way to collect these two
presenters into a single object adapter
before passing them to
the browse fragment.
And to do so,
we'll use a ClassPresenterSelector.
This is a simple class that associates
presenters with the classes they should
be used to present, like this.
Once we created an ObjectAdapter
with our class presenter,
we can add different types of objects to
it as long as it knows how to present
these classes.
And finally, we can set this
ObjectAdapter as the main adapter for
the details fragment.
Let's run the project now and
see what we get.
Watch what happens if you
select an action now.
Here the playback fragment appears.
Pretty cool, right?
Now, I know there was a lot of
code here and few new concepts.
But if you think about how much
functionality you got in return,
I hope you'll agree that
it's a good trade-off.
And one last tip,
here we use the Leanback support
library to build a catalog browser.
But you could easily use it for
something else other
than displaying movies.
For example, you might have cards
that just play weather information,
as in the Sunshine app.